[Musique]
après l'otan mon premier objectif était
d'aller se servir et ça n'a pas un
sauveur pour une raison des enfants en
bas âge et j'ai dû plancher de son
deuxième objectif était de créer et deux
ans plus tard jour est ce qu'elle est
devenue
on est en plein boum et tout change pas
inventé par ailleurs selon ce
professionnel et sans transcendance
aller
après les réalisations et on suit la
disparation pour des raisons plus si le
front social ce qui génère près tout ça
en aurait fallu reconstruire les chaînes
de la nyha à un objectif
chacun cherche à se réaliser jamais vous
avez des notions portes de la réussite
des challenges bavure et comparé lors de
l'arrêt la seule à bout du champion de
parier à concrétiser un projet est tout
neuf pieds ont cessé d'arthur le société
edwards le tout c'est que les mêmes
jours dans la chambre de la cour en a vu
ce genre de profs points se relever
comment garder la promotion et ma vie
voir la vie et les défenseurs je vous
rassure elle est sublime a été abandonné
mais à chaque fois la france de
continuer ce sont des rêves je suis
imposé parmi ces mails y en a quatre
sont foulés nous sommes encore en train
de ramper si l'ol d'accord 1ce ne vous
faisait défaut mais le biais de la
titrisation a rien de plus aux militants
de son mouvement
la deuxième c'est de savoir dernier les
problèmes lausanne s'en allait dans le
bon sens la tendance à sucre a baptisé
aux premières personnel et le même avoir
les drames qui ont tantôt le grimp est
ce vraiment si vous en savez vous où les
points positifs d
et dès les expériences précédentes
les deux sont aussi avec en sus on est
rentré dans ce match suite d une
solution n'a exploré d'autres pistes de
réalisation comme sylvie var a montré du
blé l'arizona
il va traverser les éleveurs 2011
mais ce n'est pas habité les mots même
le même coup que le rascisme haut que
les faits celui réellement de me
détruire
à l'est nord est a oscillé à grasse et
aussi du temps profite de la vie sont en
fait qu'ils étaient en passe le rambo et
photos où se nouent décidant de faire
200 opérations en déplaçant en
équipements et en profitant en avançant
sur la régisseure d'autres solutions 60
000 personnes aidées par les patients
mais pour nous il existe des phénomènes
qu'ils détestaient trois ans que l'homme
nous apprendra à visée est bien passé le
problème personnel
arrivées leur sont parfois existentielle
le coup cela vaut savoir d'abord
d'asseoir et laurent soit vous mais il
ne m'a pas le plus dans ce sens là c'est
les problèmes des enfants en situation
de voilà un phénomène qui vaut quelque
chose de fort mais les mentionner moins
de 200 mémoires a même conçu de la
publication ce drame nous sommes souvent
mur évidemment
dans la banalisation et pour la saisie
des mots et vos enfants soient ses
origines son milieu et la configuration
phase i de la convention internationale
des droits de l'enfant le droit de
chaque enfant de vivre d'avoir inhalé
210 mois
si le droit est le droit d'avoir et
noisy le roi droit à la vie le droit
d'être et cette propension elle
l'apport de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies et rend difficile parce
nasri tous les milanais
mais depuis nos sens la journaliste est
de plus en plus d'emplois dans beaucoup
de sens purement la ville et le bailleur
et lens en nombre différent pour la
charpente est aujourd'hui du personnel
pour mémoire il est structuré en les
enfants sont livrés à eux mêmes dans ce
milieu préparer la rue avec la
possibilité de manger
la possibilité de d'avoir une hygiène de
vie
ils sont exploités à l'état et les
monnaies qui sont l'une et à l'autre et
au viol on voit à l'avant à la
constitution et si jeune ils en sont
réduits aux salles de la simple zone de
l'écran par un 200 m en dessous et les
yeux brillants de faim
les yeux brillants d'espoir sur deux
fois à l'amendé ps dessus et sur le mans
- se relâche avec la même énergie
malgré le froid la pluie qui transfère
cela permet
malgré un soleil brûlant ville émard et
toute la forêt de micros c'est notre
forêt ce lundi aux enfants soc pour
system is a su leur pouvoir s'insérer
dans ce dans ce projet en leur confier
la notabilité à se perdre de vue si haut
si on peut nous apprendre à aimer montré
une vraie déception de la résidence ils
sont dépossédés vous sont une série
d'anciens d'enfance à venir
mais chaque jour entre le sens et valeur
considérable
nous avons vraiment de fuite et de
10 de valeur pour nous sachant que vous
auriez respectivement à part à cuba mais
que se cache un an seront finalement
présents sur mon jeu wii gier vous
pouvez les chinois n'ont ni être à
double tranchant pour ses enfants il
fallait des solutions pérennes sera clos
à une implication de toutes les parties
vraiment à commencer par la zone euro
des services musicaux
les mémos les fils et les ong
nous avons ce sont des civils et c'est
grâce à l'application qui pourra changer
la langue qui ont séduit 6 ans et plus
qui doivent être assez sûr de jouer de
grosses sommes
à une importation le centre d'attention
et deuxième volet définir et lu dimanche
la plupart des causes qui font six
enfants sont obligés de vivre drame et
nous aurions voulu se souvient
la son institution de contre projet n'a
pas forcément compris que jamais au
grand jamais là
zidane
quand il va à l'école pour apprendre
pour voir émerger au move centralisant
miliciens c'est pas l'heure un chargeur
à l'ofii journée trois ans gagne trop
clément
ou difficiles à prendre un engagement
personnel premier rang deuxièmement m au
cachot vous avez bu un thé troisième
engagement vis-à-vis des enfants en
situation de
le premier engagement comme un vrai à
dédramatiser nationale sinon en année
l'énergie il a essayé pour avancer et
conquérir son genou lors du deuxième
engagement vis à vis d'eux
de les mener ces tests avant de recevoir
le drame des autres sinon grammy réagi
me agi pour contrer ces nations régulant
secondes et le phrasé - ajoie se dé
chacun chacun de nous ici deviennent
ambassadeurs pour messagère ou
défenseurs de la cause de ses enfants
pour sensibiliser les autorités
sensibiliser les fondations l'émissaire
est ensemble tous ensemble
l'onu se réfléchit et trouver des
solutions véritables pour sauver ses
enfants parce que finalement ces enfants
ils sont membres à part entière
la grande famille de cette famille qui
s'appelle l'humanité
[Applaudissements]